in five four three two one what's up you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my new year's resolution already
failed huh I was gonna not curse in the
intro of the genius brain podcast but
that didn't happen anyways guys welcome
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast a podcast about anything and
everything and we're just gonna be with
you on your daily commute we got two
very special guests I don't like the
intro my guests I let them introduce
themselves go ahead
what up man your boy Chris Sosa and I'm
here and I'm queer and bhakti Duran is
here as well yes yes yes man uh happy
[ __ ] New Year Happy New Year man my
life has been different for this
[ __ ] he's single did hey you
guys are the reason how's it like being
single did it's [ __ ] good man it's
actually like it's peaceful yeah is it
peaceful well cuz hey you know it
actually like the day goes well like you
know I'm doing my thing it feels good
it's it only hits me whenever like I get
home and then I get in bed then I'm like
alright alright but throughout the whole
day I'm good I'm chilly
you know really that's so funny because
I'm with somebody that I love a lot when
she's in bed next to me I'm like get the
[ __ ] away from me man
I like being alone I like the starfish
out yeah but she only gives me this we
have a Cal King size bed which is
basically two full size beds you swish
together and I still get the sliver in
the corner to myself Daniel yeah because
she has this a heat pad on the floor on
our bed you don't want to touch that
thought you could sizzle bacon on that
[ __ ] and she likes so she gets two
blankets and a heat pad and that's what
she sleeps in every [ __ ] night and
that thing's a queen-size so she takes
up a queen-size amount a part of the bed
and I get the sliver at the end this
ridiculous man it's not even that cold
and she's
been cooking herself now it smells like
breakfast every morning Doug this cuz my
arms like bacon fat oh I saw you make
her um I saw you make your your soup
oh the ramen noodle [ __ ] a man it should
look fine no man I'd hook my [ __ ] up
like you it really did look fire like it
wasn't just good I could do a thirty
part series on every different type of
ramen packet I love I love instant ramen
like nothing else it's one of my
favorite [ __ ] things to eat huh yeah
so if somebody asked me I'm not sure
anybody asks you guys this but if I call
it the the death-row meal right so it's
like if you were on death row and they
were they were you were allowed to have
breakfast lunch and dinner what would
those foods be for you Oh
think about that Oh bummer summer and
dinner for his lunch and dinner okay so
for breakfast I'm gonna go with a twenty
so con well I'm gonna go with two years
ago well really some Papa's in it
oh so Therese Oneg with some potato key
oh it's gonna be yeah with some
tomatillo sauce that's breakfast explain
to the people what the [ __ ] that is it's
pork sausage or you can get beef but
it's like it's already seasoned and
everything and spices it's red right
right chilies in there yeah it comes out
like that to any [ __ ] house just like
that so and then you know with levels
balls and a little pop of squares some
put in potato squares right and then web
legs guys like 3mins is hella gay yeah
um where was I going with that also
lunch yeah much what do I want for lunch
um think about this this is the last
meal that you and last meal [ __ ] have
before they electrocute us and we're
raping people wow that's what you're
just putting I'm in prison because I
stole candy that's all
[Laughter]
all right this is all this is scenario
by the way in case I'll just jump in
Podcast is Jesus brain all right so uh
for lunch
I'm gonna go with and what's a fire I'm
gonna go with I'm gonna go with pizza
what type of pizza just pepperoni for
lunch lunch course is about where are
you getting that pizza from though I'm
getting the pizza from if you face
[ __ ] dough me knows I'm gonna kill
you dude Domino's whoa I'm going down my
neighbor I like dominoes beats now
there's so much so many different pieces
flights besides don't know since you
looked at domine I'm going off of what
let's see I'm going for the nostalgia I
grew up on this you got you said okay so
this is my torso gonna wear wool and I
had that every morning all the time the
Domino's Pizza that was the go-to when
we get pizza would get dumb and also
it's not it's not about like how fancy
more than much yeah cuz I'm like oh I'm
not to go you know I'm saying so for
dinner I'm gonna go with I will go with
the boil geese out I would go with the
rusted chicken with black beans and
those darkness a plantain fried
plantains yeah yeah like that yeah and
I'm going with lion I need the juice
from the chickens drizzled on my rice
with the beans on top of it and the
bloke Esau is it's just my gosh put a
Rican chicken or Dominican I guess but
what's that what's that marinated in its
just oh so we got so oil key Sal you
have the ingredients of like you put
sofrito in it so free throw has like
bell pepper onions garlic adobo sauce on
a tomato paste
you put um you know jelly grape jelly in
it you put a beer one can of beer damn
any beer or wine as well yeah it's also
a good with wine and then you put one
leaf I forgot the bay leaf oh yeah bay
leaf throw a leaf in there
oh well she's on fire make that [ __ ]
guys shout out to also salsa cooking
I know you can figure out and make
boyacky sound so you make that [ __ ] -
yeah [ __ ] I didn't even know he
was cooking he just started putting up
food [ __ ] all also social cooking is
actually my brother he's the chef I just
it's just you know we're putting it out
you know me I get down but I only know
how to make rice and chicken and and
tracing all levels so that was your
brother man that's all my brother's dish
it looks so [ __ ] good it's fire y'all
go follow Oso salsa cooking it's
delicious so does he cook
is he a caterer what does he do he just
cooks for fun right no he's been cooking
for fun for the longest but now he's
like actually saying [ __ ] it and I'm so
proud I'm so happy that he's doing this
[ __ ] because for years by the--with but
he knows for years ever since I moved
out here I've been saying [ __ ] you
that's actually I've gotten so far in my
career
that's tight though and yeah I'm a king
of [ __ ] I'm not because also wise
relationship failed so because y'all are
the [ __ ] CIA I'm going in on you
[ __ ] to save the cat time yo
[ __ ] dude say oh no man y'all don't
really like what cats people then I say
the cat that's it y'all [ __ ] going
man y'all did y'all's research y'all
found homegirl y'all went in her DM
y'all sent hers eclipse he doesn't
deserve you're gonna send her this one
black girl he's gay now oh my gosh that
was another [ __ ] show but it was cool
bad I mean [ __ ] what about you what
swish it through it you three [ __ ]
meals yeah so for me I'm gonna keep it a
little bit more Dominican than you did
my man okay um I'm gonna start off with
the third gold abyss which the drug op
was like a traditional Dominican dishes
everybody had like for breakfast and it
has a
plantains that are mashed it has
Dominican salami and
what the [ __ ] is Dominican salami oh
well from when I know for the most part
I just know that it's like predominantly
probably that's like from that area
mm-hmm
and I was like a certain seasoning to it
um but I mean I couldn't go like deep
into it what it is but it's different
from that but yes it has such a
different flavor like if you compare to
like any of the salami that I've tasted
that one for sure has like a very
distinct flavor that's very oh yeah yes
I've never had much like Dominican food
so that's you know I even a lot of
cuisines but I don't think there's that
many Dominican restaurants in LA
Oh in Florida and also the [ __ ] but not
here so it's not really something I know
too much about foods for you oh I would
love to man but you know there's one in
San Diego if you want to go there I'm
down you guys gotta show me what's up I
don't know [ __ ] about the fish it got
great baseball players so it'd be those
three things for the breakfast because
that's like the main thing that we go to
let's get that my close to your face for
lunch for lunch I would probably go for
a salad wrap just because of the
connections that I've had like in terms
of like eating because I grew a
vegetarian so I think there's a lot of
salad wrap just kill yourself in there
it's a three course dear it's a three
course meal so I mean I got the other
hand I would have never put salad in
there ever because I help you I'm gonna
be dead growing up with this guy Wow
this is my cousin by the way but they
were you were a straight vegan or
vegetarian vegetarian for 18 years so we
were like the people that we would bring
our soy like products to the household
parties because well hold on a second
you were Dominican vegetarian I mean
come to parties and we had nothing for
the negative in that life that start
from your parents it started from my dad
for my dad because my dad he started he
became a devout Hindu whenever you turn
is going on right now hold on a second
so many vegetarian Hindu what happened
to your father man
so my dad's dad died of heart disease
and began my mom's dad also did die of
heart disease so whenever he and he was
going to like a drug problem whenever he
was like growing up in New York back in
the 80s yeah Oh your dad's dead my dad
my dad's what the drug problem kind of
thing oh yeah you know think about you
all new to me it's kind of going through
it you know I grew up in New York stuff
like that um and then after his dad
passed away from heart disease and my
mom's dad also died of heart disease
later on he changed it became like
Hindus because also he told me it was
because I was born that he liked change
for the better kind of thing which was
like touching whenever I first heard it
for the first time you know I was like
okay that's beautiful I know right yeah
um but that that so he became a Hindu um
after then and he basically said that
his kids would not be eating any type of
meat at least you know until they're 18
I think so we each had a choice when we
turned 18 to be like you know should I
keep the only mistake that well really
on my 18th birthday I went straight to
KFC got a bucket of KFC a palm place is
the command because everybody was like
saying is so [ __ ] good and I just had
18 years worth of like built up like
okay he's got it KFC's like lowest tier
friends but we had a good season at one
point they did have a good season
wherever KFC was poppy yeah I mean
because people didn't know about
churches that's why you pieces of [ __ ]
turkeys chicken is fire man I think has
the best biscuits and a chicken
don't you [ __ ] say anything else
Beyonce sponsored by Church's Chicken
she gets free church's ticket for
lightweight I thought no Pappas no
that's not church's bro disrespecting
and you don't know nothing about your
life is like what Popeyes has great
seasoning right yeah but Church's
Chicken has this crunch their [ __ ] is
crunchy as [ __ ] their biscuits
hands-down the best
put a little honey on that [ __ ] that's
what I'm saying y'all are crazy I think
the Popeyes ones way better is dry
asphalt
I hope you get it I've been getting some
good ones I guess [ __ ] yeah yeah so
that's kind of the reason what's in your
salad wrap exactly though oh there's
gonna be shrimp there's gonna or I guess
it wouldn't be like oh so there's like
some meat in there [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's definitely there's gonna be
turkey there's gonna be shrimp there's
gonna be lettuce there's gonna be uh um
like all of this for sure we're gonna
have maybe a little bit of corn and uh
medium ranch dressing okay nice
keep it light so that because when I get
to dinner part which is gonna be I'm
always gonna like what my mom's cooking
as like my final kind of dinner it's
gonna be rice and beans with a side a
side a side of a soy meat swimmy that's
been seasoned
you know properly hopefully with like
some go your product I'm just gonna kill
myself no no there's gonna be meat as
well are you gonna say their last meal
usually the other people salivate my
[ __ ] I know that's dry well I might
bring some of this food over here once I
bring it over here you say so you can be
like okay I get what you're saying you
know I mean they also pork chops pork
chop cause she makes him great [ __ ]
pork chops oh well so she said [ __ ] you
to the vegan thing well she never did it
oh she was the one always eating meat
like you guys they're all eating them to
the table and she has like he didn't
[ __ ] pork chops that famous lunch and
honey so you were just smelling that
[ __ ] your whole life and you never
tasted it to u18 over and well I mean I
did break it like once I was like I had
a hot dog by accident kind of whenever
there was like a function and then the
suburb or something like that it was
like one of the server parties at the at
the pool area yeah kind of thing I take
someone on I didn't know beforehand so
your mom's [ __ ] hilarious dude your
mom's the best comic I've ever in my
life the dinner table just eating a pork
chop in front of your dad who changed
his life though this beautiful story
about why he's Hindu and that she's just
gonna eat pork
[ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] funny
Oh women are sometimes that you don't
change me [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] your heart
attack yeah damn that's pretty dope but
you guys are very emotional I'm like
that too though but then my three meals
have changed constantly and I'm so fed I
started adding like in between yeah what
if I just get a pass on this [ __ ] I
think for me how [ __ ] man actually don't
actually I don't know anymore I actually
had this written down because it was
that important to me there's like 20 80
pounds this is all I used to think about
so I I see hmm
breakfast okay I think Bret oh [ __ ] I
don't know come on man same [ __ ] you
like you're gonna get some fun damn it
would definitely so my three okay three
favorite foods on earth is Vietnamese
Korean and Japanese so it's just gonna
have to meet those okay uh what they
test Taiwanese food to my culture -
tongue
I think breakfast will be Korean food is
whatever so my mom makes like this soy
bean paste soup doesn't sound very
appetizing but it's a very like popular
Korean dish which is rice and a bunch of
Korean side dishes and that's just like
something my mom knows that I really
like so I'll probably eat that okay keep
it light
yeah I'm saying a no sell rap and then
for lunch is just gonna be a spread of
binamis food it's gonna be a good ass
bowl of [ __ ] and then it'll have this
thing called button sale button say oh
is this Vietnamese crepe it looks like
it's made out of eggs but it's not it's
like coconut milk and I think it's
tapioca or rice flour I think it's rice
water solution and it's like super
crispy they put like bean sprouts a
bunch of meat and you dip into this fish
sauce then you wrap it with vegetables
you would actually love it because it's
vegetarian you still have the end of me
oh or and then it's [ __ ] fire but you
had that vegetarian sausage mine you
[ __ ] so and then I would eat that this
is funny because I'm adding all these
meals into one meal and then I would
have a Vietnamese bun me sandwich which
is their French baguette sandwich is one
of my favorite shoes and I could eat
that all in one meal like nothing hands
down yeah and then for dinner it would
just it would
have to be sushi rooms and I love
[ __ ] sushi like sashimi like medium
fat medium fat tuna I specifically like
red snapper a lot yeah when this place
called hama sushi they do uh it's like a
small little bar they do like just had
me giddy and it's like this small place
like the size in this podcast room and
they were there so I would do sushi and
then a bunch of different Japanese I got
to eat a shitload of sushi to get fool I
don't get full off of sushi like I got
to eat like a bunch of it well you just
eat the raw fish but if you eat with
rice you get full of them rice yeah cuz
it's like and sushi too the hard part
about it is there's there's a knife
technique in to get the fish right just
to get the fish the slice right in the
portion but the important part is that
the rice tastes good because it's like
it's literally like 60% of what 60 to
70% of what you're eating mmm so a lot
of the places that you go through they
don't pay attention to the rice and so
it sucks and so my favorite part is
getting that sushi rice just right nope
you know like decent fish on it'll taste
really good
yeah am I so [ __ ] true all the
[ __ ] sushi that I have like from
grocery stores and [ __ ] like that
rice is ass it's whack and ass you got
it you got to go to one good good - a
[ __ ] dope dominican spot I'll take a
bit as a dealer I actually had sushi
right before a game room yeah that's
just [ __ ] good man um
fun fact well I don't mean I don't know
if it is but um so I used to work at a
used to work out of prison I was a CEO
what the [ __ ] now yeah so and I actually
worked in the execution unit Rick Ross
bro
yeah I'm regrows I'm the real regrowth
yeah you worked as a [ __ ] CEO I was a
CEO and I worked in the execution unit -
this is yeah yeah and a lot of people
think that you can get whatever you want
for your last meal but it's really at
least as far as the prison that I worked
in you can only you can get whatever you
want that they can make in the prison
that's why yeah so we got ok well then
now this [ __ ] changes so what the [ __ ]
can they make in prison besides [ __ ]
you know flapjacks and cereal everything
come out of cans and [ __ ] no they got
you know they
it's for sure thing is is like a lot of
his bland so you gotta add hella salt
sugar like a long pepper but um you know
they spaghetti and they got this pork
patties oh you can get like a sausage
egg McMuffin type of thing yukia yeah
you can hook it up okay man for sure I'm
gonna get me a sausage egg McMuffin okay
a hash browns of that [ __ ] a prison I
don't think there's something a delicacy
potatoes though right
yeah it's a [ __ ] helices hello
cabbage like cabbage with everything let
me tell you something my cabbage that's
one of the worst vegetables on earth
yeah and and they dig they bring it by
the big truckloads bro yeah it's just
like stuffing it like capture Sochi
that's why it has a lot of like
nutrition it should in fiber and then
wipe out all of it so yeah yeah man but
yeah I worked in the prison man I worked
there for like two years before I [ __ ]
did you see in there dude I saw some
crazy [ __ ] man
oh I can't survive in prison bro I Reno
like if I let's say like tomorrow I
shoot somebody in the face and they're
like well I get caught I'm I'm just
gonna kill myself I can't do it I'm get
[ __ ] in the ass every day I got juicy
cheeks bro I got a really high screen
and my skin hella soft dude look at me
like do you the closest thing to [ __ ] I
take my arm and just use the fold in my
bicep in my forearm as a [ __ ] just
gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] on my heart look at
my back legs got four dicks inside no
five six one in the mouth one in the ass
in the bellybutton
I got a deep-ass bellybutton to use me
in there I usually don't get out gay but
you know me the [ __ ] out of somebody man
they gonna [ __ ] me up and [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me and I know this [ __ ] oh man yeah I
see I see some wild [ __ ]
there was an inmate who actually tried
to he actually try to hang himself oh my
god yeah had a horrendous Wow
no I am so in the in the Academy they
show you like scenarios and they show
you videos of like you know ways of how
they would hang themselves and the the
main way is like taking their sheets and
tying it up at the top of their bars
whatever their bed sheets and so um I
was working the specific cell block that
I was working in was the site cell block
so there were people that were there
inmates that were like in like their own
cell they didn't have a cellie and each
one had a key to it so all the doors can
be open at the same time with the roller
at the at the end of the cellblock but
this was a specific one I had to open
each one with a key and we also had to
have a bullet like a vest on you know
because you know they could [ __ ] wall
out on you
right so this specific inmate he was
like putting things together he was like
yo why am I in this cellblock right and
so he asked me and now I I don't know
specifically why but I know that he is
obviously has to be in this cell but for
a reason because he's in the psych thing
might hear voices or whatever the case
is but you know that's not something I
tell him of course you know me so um you
know I just let him know like you know
he asked me I said I don't really know
man my paperwork just has your cell
number and and you know your ID number
and your name he'll decide I would you
know just you know just figure it out
from you know and these inmates were in
transit as well so when they're in
transit they're actually on their way to
another prison that's further but they
stopped by our prison to be there for
the weekend and then go hit the road
again right so I was only gonna have him
for the weekend so during count time we
count every three hours we count all the
inmates um and we we tally up our
inmates in the cellblock and then they
all get those papers and then all the
papers come together and lieutenant
counts and make sure all the council
right and so during count time I'm
counting and I passed
of his and he already had the she's tied
up to the top of the bars and now he's
wrapping it around his neck and I was
like yo the Academy is like it just like
split like I immediately in my head I
was like yo I've seen this [ __ ] like
this is exactly what they were talking
about and so I was like [ __ ] so I had to
like shut everything down and I was like
yo my man like yo stop like get that off
your neck and you know the rule is you
have to you have to warn them that you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna gas you I'm
gonna use my handy-dandy mace it's all I
have you know me but it's like I'm a gas
you if you don't take that off your neck
you're not allowed to gas them if
they're already hanging because you're
obviously making it worse yeah so if
they're in the process you have to warn
them say hey man I'm a Gashi
so I told them I said bro take that off
your Nick I didn't say bro but I was
like yo take that off your neck whatever
and he's like no he's he has just like
this like crazy in his eyes yes crazy
like he was like no I'm doing it I'm
doing it he kept like going about like
making the knot and I'm like yo imma
gasps you don't tighten that don't
tighten that up and he was like it's
happening it's happening I just like
he's like a three year old of shits like
don't touch that grasshopper act like
yeah yeah right right exactly don't
touch that glass don't touch that glass
just tip it over yeah so I'd [ __ ]
wasted the whole can on him Road just
started gassing them but the thing was
though I feel like this [ __ ]
done this [ __ ] before this was like a
plan because he had his little fan
facing me what so while I'm gassing him
it's blowing back on me bro so now I'm
blow I'm guessing him he's coughing I'm
coughing I'm just like I'm like trying
to call her on my radio like lieutenant
we got it whatever the code was like so
so and then you know they came running
down and he's like oh you know he's
coughing and [ __ ] he's like his eyes are
burning and he's telling the the the
lieutenant he's like yeah I'm joke I
kept track every and it's like the
[ __ ] inmates brother they're ruthless
bro the inmates they are they picking up
on what's going on and then I was like
that's what the [ __ ] was gonna happen if
you'll hang yourself dumbass like that
was a talking [ __ ]
you know what else they got at that
point I'd be the front rigger that [ __ ]
as I've been like the BS with making
jokes if somebody's [ __ ] his arms
they they just like they didn't care man
and the thing is like they still have to
go about the procedure like the process
before they go and get the inmate out of
the cell so before they get him while
he's coughing and choking his eyes are
burning they have to make sure he has
nothing in his hand so we have to say
show us your hands front and back you
know um take your fingers and go through
your hair to make sure there's nothing
in his hair razor blades yeah razor
blades go inside your your your lips
like the rub around your gums make sure
there's no red blades in there he has to
get it stripped naked and you got to you
know spread your cheeks lift your nuts
you gotta make sure everything is
cleared before we go in there and get
you so he's coughing off this whole
entire time just like everything's
burning and then that's when they went
ahead and uh
everything was clear they went in there
and got him and when they got him they
cuffed them and they're walking them out
the inmates are just talking [ __ ] you
know damn so see you painted that boy
you painted a man damn so she did
graffiti on that boy like that's [ __ ]
hot [ __ ] about that dude man like if I
was in prison though I mean this is not
even as a joke if I have nothing to look
forward to except for the cells of my of
the walls of my cell I that would be in
the same situation him I think I would
probably try to kill myself I can't I
can't imagine having my my human rights
and then my freedom stripped away from
me yeah it's a frightening frightening
[ __ ] thought I do not survive in
prison
bro it's smaller than this in this room
see I came to sell some ways much
smaller I would say like cut in half
like this is probably two cells cut in
half and you have a toilet on the back
wall and then you had the bunk bed
that's it
walls that's crazy yeah and then you
have your your your uh your cellie your
you know your other person who you're
sharing a cell with and you taking a
[ __ ] man you just got to sit there while
somebody's taking a [ __ ] you guys since
my worst nightmare ever dude has ever
had to put your paws on somebody real
quick hell no man though you're your
biggest your strongest weapon as a CEO
is your pen oh I'm gonna write you
yo straight up and they take away a
little bit [ __ ] that they would say yeah
man and and and my thing was like when
you first go in they tell you like when
you first go in you got to be hard you
got to be a cop you got to be a Robocop
if they would say like you got to be
Stern I take advantage of you yeah so
especially like looking like me I'm 18
years old too and like I was they was
just like new boots pretty boy Chris
Brownlee they was talking all types of
[ __ ]
there was an inmate that saw me in
solitary confinement he was like he saw
me through his little window I just
heard him holler out Alicia Keys Alicia
Keys I was [ __ ] whoa and that [ __ ]
you know who here you dumb [ __ ] family
there was hollering Alicia Keys and
lieutenant was like well sounds like
they're hollering at you so so that's
[ __ ] funny they're not hollering at me
cuz they call me Mariah Carey okay I was
just like man it was a it was some [ __ ]
so whenever I got armed and I was really
like trying to be hard laughs like no
just so that they would I would get that
respect
like I'm not playing around well you
know I mean like [ __ ] that new boots
[ __ ] whatever whatever like nah it's a
serious so I would take every little
thing things that like you would just
let slide just whatever
I'll tell me y'all let me see your ID
they play yo what like we do this all
time no no no give me your ID I would do
that I didn't write them up cause
there's a shitload of paperwork for them
nothing right
I would just I would just do it just so
that at the end of the day I give it
back to them it on my MN don't do that
[ __ ] when I'm working because the next
time I'm actually write your ass up so
it would be things like that of like you
have to yeah there's no got to get to it
because then it got to a level of like
they would come in there black I don't
know officer so I know so you know me
like cool keeping them cool and then I
got to loosen up be myself you still
have authority but still be like come on
man you know you're supposed to be doing
that stuff like that it can't be like
that at first no no no no cuz they know
they'll just run over you bro it's like
it's like because you got facial hair I
don't got facial hair I do it's [ __ ]
clean shaven and CEO really well you can
have a mustache it's a union job so like
union job you should give a mustache but
and that bro yeah I got six like I got
like two catfish tears coming down my
face
maybe clowning me all day call me baby
face butt cheek face all this other
stuff
yeah really start to UM I just thought
man she was wild in there bro I got a
kid there was another time the inmates
[ __ ] trolled me so [ __ ] bad bro I
can't believe this [ __ ] happen but so I
I got had to work showers right and so
there has to be an officer inside the
showers to make sure there's no [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on right or any fights or
whatever guy [ __ ] yeah and so now
just making jokes before shit's real huh
okay yeah yeah and I'm upon way you know
that [ __ ] like [ __ ] the whole like
drop the soap
yeah the the fact that the inmates say
this [ __ ] when the inmates a yeah
whatever that's why Johnson drops the
soap I'm like yo we're actually in
prison
so anyway I'm working showers right and
then an inmate he [ __ ] he'd he convinced
me he'll just like a man I know is your
first time working showers but you just
throw your shades on easy work call it a
day you know three shades aren't any
worry about it you sit there would you
boo be in and out right and so I was
like I kind of took it up like you know
I've been there for a little minutes my
first time doing I was like cool [ __ ] it
put my shades on I'm chilling so I'm
sitting in the showers man shades on and
we go and I get an officer comes and
breaks me like he comes in like you know
and so he pulls me I said social come I
say alright come on he was like why are
you why do you like them inmates tell
you to put the shades on man and I was
like I was like no I'm not I'll put them
on my selfies like nobody puts shades on
in the in the showers I was like why is
like the inmates tell you that [ __ ] to
make it so that you look like you're
you're trying to look at their dicks but
so you don't get caught you wear the
shades so you could be looking at dick I
know they know that the officers that
we're shades you're just trying to look
at dicks says you don't
so they [ __ ] with you and I was like oh
I just like slowly taking my glasses up
I wasn't looking at dick
trying to you know arrest nice not [ __ ]
movie man and I remember when I got back
like from my break the showers were
already done but I went back to the cell
bug [ __ ] I was this like [ __ ]
lockdown for the rest of the day [ __ ]
like [ __ ] piss yeah hey Robert past
that dude [ __ ] his cell block man he was
like that so you got the shades on you
still got the shades like [ __ ]
[ __ ] man too much in prison that I
might you got me that's [ __ ] funny
yeah man that's hilarious if you were a
[ __ ] correctional officer it was a
random it was hella rap before that I
was a I was working drive-through at
McDonald's it was like what the [ __ ]
jump
how does that happen okay 18 so the jump
so the jump happened like this alright I
had I went to college for like two weeks
dropped out smart guy was a [ __ ]
witness yeah and then I will put his
name on a piece of paper left
shame too many [ __ ] questions that's
really what happened it was actually I
opened up a new [ __ ] textbook and I
just like the smell of the paper I was
like oh my god the same [ __ ] for another
four years
let me [ __ ] them so I got a sentence so
I went back so I went back to uh live my
mom's and we went got me a job at
McDonald's around you know around the
corner from the neighborhood and then
today they booked me they they hired me
doing uh so Hollywood they booked me I
got booked for this becomes McDonald's
gig they had his uh you're hired
yeah so they gave you the the third
shift so I was working like from 11:00
p.m. to 7:00 in the morning
and at 4:00 in the morning correctional
officers will come and get their
breakfast right I didn't know their
crevice correction officers until I
asked this this lady boss she and I was
like you know what's that uniform
they're like oh I'm a correctional
officer I've worked at the prison that
you know sauce oh damn and I was like yo
is it like the move he's like is that
[ __ ] like for real she was just like
honey it's the easiest job you could
ever have and I was like word
it's like a daycare for men for groan
for adults yeah and I was like all right
you know how you getting this she's like
if you passed the Academy you're in
likes it you just gotta pass the Academy
so I was just like all right I looked it
up I joined the Academy or whatever and
how long's that take the Academy was six
weeks every day you know and pretty
intense yeah six weeks you know you
doing the whole like you got to do the
you know the fitness thing and then you
got to do the the guns you have to learn
how to shoot a handgun a shotgun and
rifle that's for when you're in the
pickets in case you know someone tries
to escape you gotta you know you gotta
shoot him and that's just real yo they
put that put you in the picket and
sometimes the picket was like it was
kind of like a punishment like if you
weren't doing what she's supposed to do
you know as a CO whatever they'll just
put you up in the picket you know I mean
the our our unit was called the walls
unit it was like it's like the oldest
prison I believe it's the oldest prison
there and then the walls were a hell a
high so it's like it's it's called the
Huntsville unit but aka walls unit so
they'll put you up in the picket and you
just sit there with your handgun your
shotgun just like damn which one do I
want to use on myself you're doing a
whole ten-hour shift in the Pickett and
you don't go out you don't get lunch
like you get lunch but a CEO has to come
and bring you your tray lunch and like
you know use a little pulley and bring
it up to you that's like a prison
sentence what the [ __ ] yeah man they get
you got a toilet up there and some
newspaper most likely courseö all the
pay was nice man think I was get in like
three thousand a month damn for 18 year
old kid I mean I was I was living nice
after taxes there's like 25 or some
whatever but yeah amen I was I was and
the thing was I was on a college campus
he actually you saw him and my brother
they were roommates out there in
Huntsville and I was living the college
life without going to college
I [ __ ] finessed him bro I died you
know I was like I had my own car I was
living my brother but like it was [ __ ]
dinner had my own place like he wasn't
in there yeah it was chillin you know he
had his girl so he was always with his
girl but I oh yeah man go
going to parties college parties going
to the little club that they had in
there and then go to work I will pull up
with my uniform to look at fly starts
creased looking profession he got money
yeah that's tight yeah damn got no idea
that what a [ __ ] colorful life you've
lived it it's weird man that's okay my
[ __ ] it's a weird ass like I did my
10-year decade
I hit my 10-year mark and I'd like went
back and looked at all these videos and
[ __ ] and I was like I even kind of like
shocked my I was like damn I did a lot
of [ __ ] in the past ten years of like I
was like what the [ __ ] you know and that
correction officer one always like
catches me like damn can't believe I did
that [ __ ] that's some weird stuff man I
don't think I would have ever picked up
a job like that though it's really like
being in prison you just get to go home
just 20 minutes like yeah I just said
we're just wearing two different
uniforms we're on the other side of the
bars but you're in that prison for ten
hours and it's like you're with the
inmates longer than you're with you know
your family here when I would get home
through their sleep so that would watch
that show scared straight
oh man that show made me laugh so hard
yeah it's good they got some of the
baddest kids there's no tough yeah and
then you got [ __ ] Deebo comes up to
you a little bit a little sub sweetcakes
ya know we call you a prison [ __ ]
light lunch little more focal I've never
attack like oh my god it's kool-aid on
your lips I want to kiss it off with you
hold my pocket real quick yeah literally
took his [ __ ] took his pockets out of
his pants
Hopa pocket is getting a whole this
pockets the most great thing ever
hold on pocket something was that desert
literally oh yeah oh yeah it's just
[ __ ] wild man like the wildest [ __ ]
that I'd like I shouldn't have been this
comfortable but I used to work in the
craft shop and the craft shop it was
basically like it was like a room full
of elves like they they're just making
all this shit's like there
there's the wood department then there
was a leather department like they would
make like leather bags that would make
boots that's nice they would make yeah
and the thing like the line to get hired
into the craft shop is like years like
cuz the people who are actually in there
they're never leaving because they're
nice that's like their recess yeah so
it's like hell yeah I'm gonna go I'm
gonna work for the crash I'm like they
made things for the they've made things
for the president they've made things
for like I owe this tire this is made in
the prison this is a so this little clip
right here I put the keys in my pocket
and then the clip hangs out so it's
easier to pull the keys out you know and
so all the CEOs have this thing and so
it has salsa right here and it made made
this for me yeah so what the [ __ ] yeah
so that's like so when you go into the
craft shop they just get to stay there
if they if they get in and they could
just choose to leave whatever um well
there's there's certain like they have
like a shift so like they got they go
o'clock into the craft shop and then
they leave but it's it's damn near like
majority of their day that they're in
the craft shop I would do that they'll
go have lunch and then come back I would
do a half shot because I got to keep
busy
yeah I lose my mind yeah and the art in
there bro is insane don't ya there's
nothing but time yeah man and they're
doing dope [ __ ] and then they got you
know the metal part to that's you know
they're welding they're making all these
things man and they come up with some
creative [ __ ] bro but the thing is I'm
surrounded with inmates who have life in
prison so they really have no [ __ ] they
give no [ __ ] you know and they have all
these tools bro the kills that's what I
was saying like that like that's what
and might think what the thing was is
like to like kind of like ease your mind
they don't want to lose this opportunity
y'all then never get it back they'll
never get it back and you know that the
they'll you know get more time or
whatever the [ __ ] whatever would happen
so I'll take a climb on whatever so it's
like it was like I went act when I came
in man it was it was it was literally
like I was like the Santa like hey hey
hey
get to go to work cuz like I had the
keys there would there be like behind me
excited like for me to open the door so
they can hurry up and get in and you
know make that [ __ ] that they worked on
the other day yeah I would like I
wouldn't mind that if I was in prison
doing that stuff yeah man just I just
don't want to be around people I don't
mind as long as I'm being active and I'm
making am creating [ __ ] yeah I get to
get my creative Willie's out yeah but if
I'm in there just I know that I play
football with people or play basketball
and she I don't wanna do that stuff yeah
there was a lot of racist jokes I got
but that seems like stuff though that's
like if you're playing basketball on
things like that it's more stuff that
you're like you're still like somewhat
free choice to do that and other stuff
seems more like is that that stuff being
used by like corporations that are using
the [ __ ] jail as like a like a
machine oh yeah as long as I keep busy
I'm oh well I gotta get the memory of
getting my arms [ __ ] rug burn on my
forearm so buckle real quick and and and
also like yo there's inmates who they've
paid for their kids college with that
like a day they can actually make money
it just goes to their books and then
they can transfer money from their books
to an actual account man dude cuz I had
a a couple buddies went to prison man
and one guy he went to prison won't say
he was my buddy cuz he was like seven or
eight years old than me and he used to
go to our church but you know he tried
to become born-again Christian type of
[ __ ] really work out well for him he
went back to thuggery oh but he prison
for like five years because for what do
you call this it would be when you rob a
car was that called grandpa yeah grand
theft so he [ __ ] jacked the car right
so he went to prison for like five years
or some [ __ ] like that
okay that fool told me that the first
night that he was in prison he heard
somebody crying cause he's getting
[ __ ] in the ass oh and he was like
[ __ ] 19 at the time and you know [ __ ]
like that is where I was like I can
never go to prison yeah I can't do it
dude I can't even resist sometimes when
I get to a asian massage and the lady
massages me too hard
say [ __ ] I just let her beat me up yo
that's the thing nicer they'll say cuz
they'll be like you've been asking the
beginning of like hard soft likes off my
media oh sorry
and I'm like media because I don't sound
like a [ __ ] like I really do soft black
I'm like do medium right I've asked for
soft before and they're just like
caressing yeah it's actually just I'm
dumb dude I so hard
give it to me oh and I hate it erinite
tired I hate it every time so I had I do
a couples massage with people right so
Julia you know you met Julia from JK
right oh yeah so when we hang out we
have this thing we go eat then we go get
a massage right because it's like 20
dollars cheaper if you do a couples
massage
really and so this [ __ ] she likes
getting her spirit massage like ladies
these ladies go into her past so every
time they asked for the massage they
asked her first and they go would you
like a ha the medium was half right she
goes really hard please and I'm waiting
for them to ask me right but because she
says really hard they assume that I want
the same intensity
she was really hard then and they don't
even ask I'm waiting for them to ask for
ultra and then she just starts and I'm
like but I can't say anything because I
don't want to be like a little [ __ ]
when she's over here like this feels
really good yeah all you hear it just
sounds like somebody's [ __ ] cracking
open a bag of Doritos chips just crack
crack crack all over my body don't give
a [ __ ] about me I think she just does it
to [ __ ] with me at this point
oh my god like she would hear me and I
exhale really shut this is like are you
okay sir and I go yes I am perfectly
fine and they use their elbows their
sharp ass elbows and they're just like
jamming that [ __ ] into your collarbone
like what are you doing yeah and how
does this help me I don't know I'm
leaving feeling more hurt than when I
came in I had the first time I ever had
a deep-tissue asian massage is at this
place out in Chinatown and they're
supposed to be what they call quote
unquote really good which basically they
just did when we tie on your ass for an
hour right but first time I ever had
when I was getting the [ __ ] massage
and I was like
damn dude like this guy is [ __ ] me up
I can't destroy me man I'm like this guy
must be jack I look up it was like a
eight year old Asian lady what is wrong
with you dude
where where's this source of strength
coming from this [ __ ] was praying to
Buddha for 10 hours for strength to
massage me and she [ __ ] me up dude she
beat me up she goes do you feel pressure
here I'm like yep she's got it tomorrow
today need to send dust oh give a [ __ ]
about me man a man I like I think Asian
massages are one of those things like I
always find it weird when white people
get aged massage just like you guys know
you guys are used to that sweetest [ __ ]
you know were they with it looks like
there but it was like kinetic sand or
something yeah I mean but when they go
to like asian massage I always find a
where's like you like this [ __ ] that's
like damn you guys don't have enough
struggle to go through this [ __ ] man
that's crazy
that's too much man it hurts it really
hurts and I don't know it cuz they they
would say they'd be like too hard I'm
like no perfect yeah there's like this
funny thing that happened me when she
this lady yeah got on my back she put
her knees in my ass cheeks started
rotating her knees and she started
kicking my calves the weirdest sensation
ever need the ass-kicking my cat [ __ ]
crazy man yeah but it feels so good
whenever you're you're done with them
though right
I compared to the other massages I mean
if I had a knot and they took it out it
feels really good but during that time
it's just like I have fallen asleep in
this [ __ ] something I just want to fall
asleep I have sometimes I have and and I
I kind of like I kind of freak myself
out like yo you just trying to fell
asleep on somebody's [ __ ] you up yeah
well somebody's really like they could
really do some things to you you know
what I'm saying but I mean oh well okay
wait
when I was out in Vegas not too long ago
it was like 10 o clock and when I'm when
I'm on flights my back tightens up a lot
I just wanted a regular [ __ ] massage
so the spas and the hotels were closed
so I had to go to like you know a town
to get a massage yeah it's like 10:30
maybe around there or some [ __ ] trying
to get massage time you tweeted the [ __ ]
out close so [ __ ] irritated mm-hmm
like every [ __ ] place that I went
they wouldn't give me a massage and they
were open now so I can I get a massage
they're like oh kind of massage you want
I was like a deep-tissue they're like we
don't have anybody and I'm like you
don't have anybody I literally see
[ __ ] like three women right here
somebody [ __ ] massage thing not that
kind of massage and I'm like mmm so okay
whatever I just want a regular massage
yeah and so I went to a next place and I
was like yo can I get a massage it
wouldn't take me either cuz I guess like
with what somebody like no you want to
get my side is that the jackoff thing is
just way more money so they would rather
just get that than have to work on this
200-pound man and actually do work at 11
o'clock at night
I just want to jack me off and then move
on and get more money but I'm like I
wanna [ __ ] must somebody give me a
[ __ ] massage okay pissed yeah I
finally found one and he finally gave me
one but it was terrible this what you
don't want to get your kicks up the
world they were mad at me for being a
stand-up guy like no I want a regular
[ __ ] massage oh look at Yumi's the
special would you Christian or something
I come here all the time but Christian
people know yeah life is crazy dude so
you're single you single I am damned it
was unless I'm you got a girl oh it's a
while ago man it was like three years
ago yeah I'm good no lady for you we
talking through oh you be talking to
people coming to LA try to be all cute
and [ __ ] is a right so it's all
different vibe out here there you really
gotta like change how you do the world
how you approach things and it's hard to
let your your yeah I mean yeah it was a
little harder right that's what I
noticed when I first came to LA I was
like women are a little more difficult
out here I don't know what that is I
don't know either man and a big I mean
it's just it's it's California is too
California Dream it's like this whole
which choice I think that's what is so
much choice everybody is like an actress
or that you'd be looking for somebody
who got a lot of money or something like
it's such an interesting thing because
they're not as open to conversation
right when I was out in Houston write a
very easy to talk to this is open for
conversation this means it's gonna go
somewhere but at least the conversation
starts she's very warm yeah but over
here it's a little different they kind
of already stand off it's just like did
you make that fine I'll just try to have
a conversation like what's wrong with
you yeah like no thanks first of all you
are way uglier than me you don't get to
say no thanks to me all right
what the [ __ ] I'm not that cute but you
[ __ ] ugly don't dare you Thanks
thanks to you you [ __ ] [ __ ] right
here you I don't know man that little
girls is especially even girls like from
LA like or the valley they just like
vanish on you out of nowhere at least
for my experience yeah dating a girl
from out here that like they'll they'll
really like get to know you they'll dig
in like you guys are like really vibe
and you think it's like oh [ __ ] this is
actually like this Harold Oh piss [ __ ]
she gets it she she's not really the
industry doesn't really faze her so she
doesn't play that game yes yes you grew
up on it's all just chill and then like
on a Monday just you won't hear from her
at all gone ghost like I didn't really
know what ghosting was until he's up to
disappear on you till this yes thing is
the options thing ghosts on anybody in
your life uh no I mean don't let okay
well I wouldn't no no I wouldn't ghost
it would just be the UH that the the
energy would change so like I'll keep
answered
so where you kind of just catch that
Ghost yeah yeah yes I'm saying I
wouldn't just go ghost the only time I
would go ghost it's like I end up
getting a girlfriend and then now I
gotta cut people off the only the only
girl I ever go stand on per se was a
girl that I hooked up with when I went
to Princeton for a college show right
she's really cute and stuff whatever
those things were fine this was during
the time I was on a break with my with
my other the girl that I was with a girl
we were broken up at the time before
got back together so that's some free
card whatever get you and I go stood on
her because it was first of all she was
an international student so she went
back to Australia so you know nothing's
supposed to happen but that she just
started messaging me a lot and I have a
hold on a second like I thought it was
mutually agreed like this was just a
one-time thing and then we just move on
and life's good or whatever yeah and I
think she got really attached and it was
something really [ __ ] small that made
her really like me more was that I
remembered her name mmm cuz you know
like you're doing meet-and-greets you're
meeting a lot of people and then I saw
her at a bar I was like what's up and I
said her name oh my god you remember my
name and best just the end of story
that's all it's okay well look at that
you're a very sweet girl then she
started messaging me through this
message at mrs. crane message F call
Kakao and she was messaging me
constantly in outside what is cacao
cacao is I don't know what the [ __ ] it
means but it's just like a messaging app
okay it's like it could be called
Bluebird or some of that I could be
wrong creepy blowing be mad at me I
don't know but yeah I think like what
she took which was supposed to be a
quick hookup into something a little
more mmm that's when I got a little
weird and what I should have done was
just been more straightforward about it
but I was you know I was like what 25 26
I didn't know I freaked out and I was
like uh don't respond he's responding
hey man these dating apps are out
because I hopped on you back on it huh
thing is is like you got to delete it
after like two weeks it gets dangerous
and it is for me I go D it gets deep and
it gets disgusting what you mean
disgusting cuz you could just find
yourself in a rabbit hole cuz you know
you're not getting that you're not
really getting them though the bad ones
cuz the bad ones are really just like
they're not even a real [ __ ] profile
they just make the app look good and
then those are like the ones that you
get like a little paid promo you get a
little Instagram oh dude like sorry
Instagram models you know a nice looking
person to you know be like oh my god
this is a grandpa yeah it's what you
mean yeah and so those and then those
those aren't active and then you got to
go another tier below right you got yeah
and then get a little complicated yeah
yeah yeah then they those are kind of
just like there they're there
not there too you know they're just
there to just chat or does they really
want to be friends we get the [ __ ] up
yeah what the [ __ ] is this then you got
to go another tier where it's like
there's there's that low-level things
trying to [ __ ] they just trying to [ __ ]
but it's like they're they're older
oh yeah cuz you know bigger you know and
the thing is it's fine and then you ends
up being like oh [ __ ] cuz they're more
mature they don't got dumb people then
like [ __ ] those my head yeah let me see
that dick like for real and it's just
like you know it's a being like on this
like weird [ __ ] where I'm like showing
my dick to a 56 year old you know I'm
saying it's like what is going on
they're like oh man you know what I
would deal with that first well I would
take out my teeth and to the side and
give you these gummy gums man and so oh
and and I'm over here just like you know
it's dark I'm in my room by myself and I
was looking at me I'm like don't look at
me like it's just it man - we're like
all right I got a delete this [ __ ]
always it always happens I give it I go
way too deep it gets way too you know
hey trainees is [ __ ] how you eat a lot
of those you know what though I'm at the
save your ass real quick I found out
that [ __ ] is not a politically chrome
my bad my bad
so what's the I'm sorry I don't know
what it is but I know it's I know that's
not the word okay because I remember I
just found out that [ __ ] is also
something that you know okay okay okay
okay well uh things like trans trans
transgender transsexual okay sexual okay
shoutouts to the trans people oh yeah
yeah oh no no way to finish cuz cuz
first of all I'm about to let let it
know now y'all be bad as [ __ ] in these
damn apps
y'all get it's like heaven no there's
some fine ones and I'm like wait what is
happening here and the thing is you have
to pay attention you have to read you
have to watch the you know read these
Detailers it but the thing is like
there's you know what I really
appreciate when they do say like in the
bio hey I'm TS or translate but you
gotta type back is this is the dick
there or not and then they go it's not
there then you a woman what's up
yeah and what's the what's the key in
which your voice is at what you speak
well that's what I'll say we in the same
option right now or your lower or higher
octave well that's and that's what I'm
saying like and again especially like if
you're like [ __ ] horn is for a game
pay attention you're just like hitting
everybody up yo yo what's up yo you up
what was a you it can't like I've
definitely had times like super amateur
mode where I'm just like hitting people
up and then they'll be like oh yeah I'm
down to suck that dick and I'm like oh I
hope it's fat and I gotta see the thing
is though it's like they they still have
a pee-pee and when you have a pee-pee oh
that's less you have the mentality of a
pee-pee so you're like yeah hell yeah
I'm down and then you go and then it's
so cuz whenever whenever they hit me was
like hey I'm Matthias I'm like then you
got a dip like bro why would you do that
all you gotta do you gotta asses is is
the elephant trunk still there or
somebody poach it like what happened is
it again poached or not no I don't I
really don't appreciate when the
conversation go what like if you know
it's just completely just do you don't
catch it I didn't look at details I'm
not looking at shoulders next hands like
I'm not looking at these things and now
just like and the conversation goes all
the way and then at the end they go yo
you know I'm with tears where I'm like
bro should've told me in the in the
beginning that's if you're honest you
know I'm saying like that's [ __ ] up
you know I mean at the end of the day it
is I'm you know my horny ass right yeah
but oh yeah it has happened to me before
where I'm like it's just that the the
the bad thing is like I just wish you
were honest in the beginning because
then you know there's this whole thing
that happened it's like just the
beginning yeah we could just figure it
out then like no no I'm not saying
anything about your lifestyles just
that's just not what I [ __ ] with man I
was like that I've had messages saying
like oh your finest [ __ ] did it and I
don't I'm not gonna see him be a dick
and be like yo I don't [ __ ] with y'all
on foot yeah I might push ei tit and
then keep it moving you know I'm saying
I got hit up on my demos like actually
just the other day there's a gay man who
told me he was gay and you'll just say
hey no disrespect but I think you're
fine as [ __ ] and I was like
you know what I appreciate it I'll take
the [ __ ] compliment hell yeah this
floor over here just flexing on us right
now
okay some transsexuals transgenders
everybody to people
a donkey yesterday came out to me and
kiss me riding my bud host any month and
I was like thank you very much all teeth
and the gay community I'm a dime so I'll
take a man but yo cuz body is like like
I got so happy when he moved over here
band I was cuz if you know it's family
you know it means so without a dad I was
like yo come live with me man it's gonna
be double I got hell and god I got
another there man you know well yeah I
can't stand this [ __ ] like I
really hate it I was like I really was
like what the [ __ ] did I do why did I
make this decision why is he living with
me why why why because this guy is the
biggest troll I wouldn't say that you
know people lose their own of course you
wouldn't
yeah he's a foot control bro it's
there's always something that cuz you
think that I'm like really flexing right
now but this guy everything he says is a
flex of like why he's so great that's a
damn lie
that's a lie bro every time he like it
messages me or anything that has to do
with something he creates he's like
Brahma [ __ ] genius bro I'm a fussy
but tell me we're gonna be on Jesus
brainy's like you mean it we're gonna be
on my brain or whatever i sat down on
the toilet in my big touch the water
should say like I [ __ ] hate when that
happens man
especially when it's not a regular still
touch the water weird you know to me
that's very douchey come on buddy
you're a troll man and where did it come
like where why are weird that it even
stalled it started from my mom when I
mean it what I'm saying intro that's not
like the internet version of choice like
the same with you it's like you're
[ __ ] what your boy is kind of [ __ ]
yeah that kind of stuff more so but for
my mom actually like you were saying
like she's really like the funny person
[ __ ] tell eating pork chops from the
family that lady's hilarious dude I love
her already I mean [ __ ] steak she's
like chopping a chicken's head off right
in front of dad
I was like hilarious yeah I know she's
great guys I never I never even knew
that because she was always so quiet at
the parties I never knew she was a
troubled girl she was super stressed
like I mean growing up like until after
like the kids left up a house like she
still had to be like such a mom and I
was telling him the other day like any
woman like for them I mean if they're a
mother like they got so much [ __ ] to do
like I was doing my chores the other day
and just some simple [ __ ] around the
house and I was like this took all day
and I'm like man I'm Monica get home and
then do some more chores for all the
kids at the house and then do that all
over the weekend same thing I'm like man
there's a lot of [ __ ] energy it takes
yeah that's how the mom was out there
you know you know saying how was your
mom I was a crazy ass [ __ ]
I loved her though doctor like almost
every other day on the phone yeah
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] I love her to death
she's just some funny-ass [ __ ] like my
mom's like the type of person to like I
like talking abut she's just a fun
person to talk to but yeah we had she
there's one thing they were I call that
our [ __ ] and it was such a funny
conversation cuz I was telling her about
some marital issues that my friends have
just so I could get some advice from her
right uh-huh
and the first thing she says after I
told her like some of the behaviors that
the woman was having towards the guy and
they both agreed on this so you know it
came from both sides and my mom says
like I can't believe she would do that
he should leave her immediately
I was like why don't you say that
because she was what kind of person
would behave that way towards the the
love of their life I was like you threw
a loaded rice cooker' at her dad's head
and she got really quite she goes you
remember a lot of things you threw a
loaded rice cooker at our dad's head you
almost cracked his head open
he said something or something like to
get it my dad always has something
[ __ ] like but then you know at the
time like I always say this want to tell
these stories just to frame it in the
right thing you know we're an immigrant
family were broke his [ __ ] life is
stressful my dad's trying to get his
master's in theology trying to be a
pastor or
business 80 hours my mom's working at
the church on her son they shouldn't
have a single day off for like 30 years
man that's really big bro like we like
to blame a lot of things well I mean
naturally really like man my parents
they're you know they they got a divorce
a lot of times was divorced like people
who had divorced parents would be like
yeah my life was shitty my parenting I
had lived how to live with my mom and is
this net but it's like at the end of the
day man
your parents are still human beings who
had their own individual lives yeah that
made choices that didn't know what the
[ __ ] did you know I'm saying like I
talked to my parents in you know on
their own I finally asked them their
story like a couple years ago like
actually I call my male like how did it
go could tell me the very beginning from
when you met dad till now right to now
and you know we're on the phone with
hour and a half just going in and then
you know I got that story and then asked
my dad same thing hey man let me know
what went down from the moment this and
that and there are moments where they
they match though they're there even
then there were moments of like this was
his perspective and this was her
perspective and I was like I could only
imagine if like if that was actually
like if they actually picked up on that
perspective they communicated that or we
know whatever the case was like for my
dad my dad was like super old-school so
he was like he didn't want my mom
working he wanted to do all the work get
the money and then have her at the house
raise us and you know cook and you know
all these things where he was like let
me hold down the house and you could
just be comfortable and do like that
that was my dad's mentality my mom she
was always held independent she could
moved out at 15 and went to go be a
nanny for like some rich white lady like
a real said well she's our color our
aunt now but you know she was like you
know always doing her own thing and she
met my dad
from then on she's never lived on her by
herself ever like she's never live on
herself so she was always having to be
dependent with that wasn't even her
style so like being at home [ __ ] with
her like she wanted to go get a job she
wanted to like she would be outside
mowing the lawn like she would do [ __ ]
that's like I need to get the [ __ ] out
of here I don't want to be in this [ __ ]
and ended up you know being a whole [ __ ]
show with like the family like she
didn't
she moved to Texas and she didn't feel
um you know comfortable because she
didn't have any family out here and you
know my dad saw the family were kind of
like their wheat roll the whole family
trolls so it's like she was getting
trolled and it wasn't like her thing so
that was I ended up being the thing but
it was like damn man like I was really
hard on the idea of like mom why would
you want why you know we didn't make the
choice why would you split with my dad
like we didn't want to do that [ __ ] I
wish I thought that was selfish and then
you know it's same thing with my dad of
like yo why were you being an [ __ ] to
my mom and now that I'm gonna do it I'm
like I came out I was like mother's like
from your dad's perspective he's like
well I'm gonna be the bread earner I'm
just gonna work all you got to do is
take care of the family that's it yeah
that's how I like it and this is fair
trade-off your dad is very old-fashioned
right where'd your dad probably didn't
realize like when you told your wife to
just do that you actually didn't just
tell her to live a cushy life you're
taking her identity yeah that's who she
is
yeah for I met you I had my life in who
I was yeah essentially said was after
you had this kid you don't matter
anymore now it's about this family yeah
si yo yeah that's a really hard pill to
swallow yeah cuz you know I think a lot
of moms kind of go to that issue where
the moment that they have a kid you stop
becoming Jessica you're like oh you're
you're Denise's mom right it was like no
I'm Jessica like I'm this person but I
had this child so you know you kind of
lose that identity when you become a
parent some people are okay with it I'm
okay if I have a kid you know let's his
name is a paper clip so paper clip thumb
but Dad right right yep I'm okay with
that I'm okay with being known as the
dad yeah you know but I think other
people who hold on to their identity
really hard which I don't think is an
issue they just like that piece for
themselves right yeah right cuz I'm okay
being you know David tell my homies but
if I somebody doesn't know me and they
go Amen your thumb busts dead yes I am
yeah my name not a nickname on his
birthday but so yeah [ __ ] yeah well well
guys that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast you know the
reoccurring guests over here Christy no
Chris Sosa and bat
Garron you know I'm saying yeah so what
can they find y'all you find me a back
Rock on Instagram and that's it you can
follow me at Christie no salsa on all
platforms Facebook Instagram Twitter
y'all can also follow our podcast and
mati and I have a podcast called keepin
it real
no Gianna keepin just keepin it trill
and it's on iTunes and Spotify so uh
subscribe to us write us that five star
you know I'm sayin
and again shout out to your followers
man jeez brain ya know it's cool really
fun because a lot of times you know
they'd be like yeah bring him back you
know be it was in that specific episode
it was like oh it was a big no-no but
amen [ __ ] was hard man that was pretty
cool I kind of be rabid the real man be
wrapping myself man there's nobody's
gonna have anything they already know
about me you know that that's time man
hey shoutouts to you guys ruined his
life
I really do appreciate it hilarious for
me man thought they really thought they
figured it out they were like they were
like oh my gosh go to her page see what
she's gonna happen right now they're
literally breaking up right now did we
do this like it was like a whole thing
like now is the timing of it yeah you
know people there the and it's not even
really like my hardcore fans either
they're like that don't [ __ ] with cats
type of people if you are a fan and you
went as deep as to go that deep into
somebody's random life that's pretty
crazy you're a [ __ ] psychopath yeah
and yep I hope the same thing happen to
you [ __ ] you bet we're not the reason
why they play a lot of their stories it
was it was literally just the timing of
when you posted it cuz we broke up like
13 times before that notice we broke up
like a week before you posted it but we
recorded that episode like months before
that so it's just the timing of it so it
was just like it was it was it was just
perfect don't [ __ ] with cash alright
don't you catch the genius brain podcast
on all audio platforms if you want to
ask questions about his personal life
and see what happened you got it listed
on the [ __ ] keep it a trill pod
yeah that info is oh yeah he's also on
that episode too so check out that
episode she listened to that podcast
because that's where the dirty [ __ ]
happens
yeah that's where they where's over the
info is so I'm not gonna put it on here
yeah it's podcast oh you keep it a trill
podcast and we'll catch y'all next time
peace